[Musique]
ah ah
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens on
parler sport c'est le troisième numéro
de cette saison sur tb 78 au programme
comme toujours une dose de bonne humeur
des analyses sportives et surtout des
coups de gueule et d un débat nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite c'est un redoutable
plus tard c'est aussi un redoutable
chroniqueur c'est notre consultant
cyclisme on l'a d'or vous l'adorez on le
surnomme le capitaine lilia de jarrier
listao club de vélizy 78 avec nous on va
pouvoir dire ancien pistard en sa piste
à avoir accroché je pense que je pense
que le confinement et le président a eu
raison eu raison de moi
ravagé le pistard 2010-78 a cédé 6
décembre même si je re promène son
médecin le jour si je dois dire un jour
jorge lavelli c'est sûr on continue
notre tour de table musique il fait
partie des meilleurs chroniqueurs de
l'histoire de la télévision elle connaît
tout sur tout certain de son homme
l'encyclopédie moi je préfère le surnom
a dit tagliani lover grégory canal et
journaliste chez tv 78 est avec nous
pendant une heure bon je me tirais
bonjour jan bonjour à tous très heureux
très triste d'apprendre la retraite
sportive de yann on a en parlé de
l'année un feu de la retraite de
françois pervis donc c'est décidément
une année vous avez pas les difficiles
pour le message sur les réseaux sociaux
pour l'annoncé des mises arrière j'ai
pas mes temps de gestation jour le jour
en tout cas vous êtes le meilleur
chroniqueur de l'histoire grégory un oui
est dans une année on le répète un ou
l'italie a remporté tous mais cette
année on en parle avec yann juste avant
ça s'est terminé avec la ligue des
nations lui quand même le
la victoire au paris roubaix qui donc un
été italien qui s'est poursuivi quand
même jusqu'au 3 octobre avec sonny
colbrelli qui s'est imposé sur le
paris-roubaix bell id belle année pour
l'italie on continue à ma droite musique
c'est un basketteur professionnel il a
une énorme carrière il est passé par
chalon roanne nicosie mentor monaco il
est joueur de la république
centrafricaine aujourd'hui et joua
trappe et il espère accrocher une montée
en nationale 2 en fin de saison magic
mike mokongo est avec nous pendant une
heure donc jean miquel bonjour à tous
comment allez-vous très bien très bien
je me fais vraiment un plaisir de vous
retrouver depuis le confinement assuré
que ça fait plaisir de retrouver tout le
monde oui vous étiez venu dans
l'émission mais à distance c'est bien ça
exactement et la bronzette sur ce
plateau avec tous les chroniqueurs la
montée en nationale 2 pour trappe c'est
pour cette année oui j'espère j'espère
en tout cas on a bien commencé la saison
donc j'espère qu'on va continuer sur
cette bonne augure on vous le souhaite
en tout cas merci on termine à ma gauche
musique c'est notre superstar dans ce
sur par les sports à chaque émission et
fait toujours le show il adore faire des
blagues et il a une vraie partie du
tonnerre mesdames et messieurs genlis
ex-coach de plaisir est avec nous
quand allez-vous genre ouais bof
formigal bonjour à tous vous avez l'air
en forme aujourd'hui un ça va je suis la
situation
sinon je le fais pas et comme d'habitude
vous avez révisé aux fiches et ça ne se
vende plus avec elle par contre j'ai pas
trop compris l'histoire de pinard 9 78
le pinard pistard
j'ai pas compris je vous dis aussi bons
les blagues ça commence avec jean tout
de suite une image insolite pour
commencer certains chanceux ont pu
croiser killian mba ph rafa qui mit au
carrefour de trappes il semblerait qu'il
se soit arrêtée faire quelques petites
courses avant leur match contre rennes
dans le championnat de france on ne sait
pas trop ce qui leur a pris mais ils ont
fait une photo au milieu des rayons a
comme vous avez pu le voir tout
simplement une petite réaction autour de
cette table grégory moi je pense que ça
ramène ça vous a surpris cette photo oui
ça nous a surpris parce que bah déjà sur
le procédé faut rappeler que le psg
c'est devait se rendre à rennes il y
avait météo désastreuse ce week-end là
donc ils ont dû et faire le chemin en
voiture et en vannes un petit peu à la
dernière minute un petit peu la dernière
minute oui c'est une image sympathique
d'un foot des footballeurs qui sont
parfois starifié ils sont souvent
starifié un peu plus accessible je
trouve que c'était une bonne image qui a
donné la bonne humeur jarrier ou valider
complètement on devrait même en voir
plus souvent pour pour montrer qu'ils
sont comme nous tous quoi voilà
c'est pas ils ont deux bras deux jambes
en effet ils brassent des millions
économiquement mais mais voilà c'est des
êtres humains et ils ont droit de vivre
normalement et en fait c'est aussi ce
côté starisation qui fait que mais ils
ne peuvent plus vivre normalement ils ne
peuvent pas sortir normalement et c'est
bien et c'est bien dommage pour eux jean
vous êtes d'accord on fait la même chose
au carrefour de deux volets sont fermés
c'est pareil en fait autant de vues sur
les réseaux fait non mais c'est pas ça
il a dit se soit déjà comme tout le
monde faut arrêter de deux parce qu'il
faut un truc comme ça il faut une photo
de donner les rayons ça fait les grèves
ça fait la une forte qu'au fond on
retient que ces conneries dans
ce soit les joueurs de foot et point
final son année sportive comme toute
comédie à grégory ça fait du bien
finalement ressasser leurs conditions je
le rassure même marie monroe faisait
kaka donc voyez ils sont comme tout le
monde sur des instruments plus que la
photo moi je trouve le truc sympa aussi
à retenir c'est le fait de s'être
déplacé un peu comme dans le monde
amateur il avait pris des mini bus des
voitures parfois même personnel pour se
rendre à rennes on n'a pas l'occasion de
voir ça tout le temps dans mon vin
commence alors à paris ils ont perdu 1,8
c'est à cause du stress
déclaré à carfos allegra ça leur a coupé
les gammes d'accord avec jean s'est
finalement fait ça devrait être comme
cela sur notre ceux qui n'aiment pas le
voir ne vais pas parler de ça parlait
tout assez naturel jeudi ils sont dans
la vie comme co comme nous voilà ils
sont on ne veut pas en parler on ne veut
pas faire un plat parce que il y aurait
donc pris nos photos habchi comme ça
déjà un petit comme ça c'est pas vos
magasins de s'asseoir par terre de ses
dollars ces deux là
mike est ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous connaissez déjà ce carrefour où
vous jouez
non franchement je connais pas du tout
après je suis d'accord avec tout le
monde je suis dos au mur les photos
n'ont même pas encore arrivé mais non au
delà de ça après ils ont monté un côté
assez sympa il n'était pas obligé non
plus de faire la photo et l'ont fait et
puis et puis voilà ça les rend aussi
humain normal comme tout le monde quoi
est-ce que ça fait du bien aussi à
l'image de m pap et à ce moment voilà
c'est l'un des footballeurs le plus cher
de l'histoire du football est ce que ça
lui fait du bien tout simplement son
image
je sais pas si ça fait forcément du bien
son image en tout cas moi je rejoins
tout le monde dans le sens où c'est des
gens comme tout le monde donc il fait un
métier qui est formidable c'est un très
bon joueur après ça les empêche pas
d'être humble et puis voilà c'est
des gens sans qu est ce qu on sait ce
qu'ils ont acheté non on ne sait pas
c'est qu'ils soient violées parce que le
vin de les faire le plein d'essence
parce que ce carrefour ce qu'il faut à
ce qu il est et le dessin c'est
exactement c'était on a ctc un carrefour
qui est intégré dans une station-service
attrape froid que c'est en bord de
nationale 10 et ainsi j'ai pas de
bêtises et en fait ils ont profité de ce
moment là pour aller faire quelques
emplettes dans le supermarché
mais du coup on ne sait pas qui va leur
faire plus souvent avec qu'ils ont peur
des contraires
bonjour désolé on va passer aux
prochaines thématique des surgelés c'est
super important pour voir un complot
mais on va le voir avancer en émission
alors nous allons maintenant passer aux
problèmes de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler à football et de la coupe
de france les clubs binois sont en
grande forme cette année coup de
projecteur sur le boxeur évinois à tony
yoka les instances pourrait lui retirer
sa médaille d'or olympique acquise en
2016 mais avant de développer
on va continuer à parler de killian mba
p
[Musique]
on va donc continuer à parler de kylie
ann m bape et dans ceux ci en parler
sport vous le savez toute la planète
football le sait qu'il ya un mba paix
sera libre l'été prochain après à cinq
ans passés au paris saint germain il
pourra donc signer où il veut dès le 1er
janvier l'été dernier le prodige
français voulait quitter le club de la
capitale pour le real madrid il a
annoncé lui même lors de différentes
interviews des bleus octobre là
également dit qu'il n'a pas aimé la
communication de leonardo sur son
transfert le directeur sportif du psg ne
voulait pas le laisser partir à la fin
du mercato alors qu'il était au courant
depuis juillet aujourd'hui il ne ferme
aucune porte il peut signer où il veut
et peut-être au psg la question sur ce
thème mba paix peut-il encore rester au
psg oui ou non voter non oui ou non oui
pour vous faire un petit duel entre les
gens l'adorent kimial mbacké diagne
jarrier
gens vont commencer je commence à
l'aimer gérer votre client l'ump
attention
non pas du tout alors je dis non je dis
moi pour moi non il faut pas qu'il reste
il faut pas qu'il reste pour moi pour la
seule bonne raison c'est qu'aujourd'hui
au psg il a il a montré tout son talent
les années qu'il a joué ici là
aujourd'hui il se retrouve avec deux
autres monstres du football qui ce que
sont messi et
et neymar
sortir le deuxième je suis là celui-là
votre compte steam énerve messi et
neymar et que là je pense que s'ils
restent trop au psg il risque de ne plus
être un petit peu intrigué mais la star
incontestée et incontestable de l'équipe
et risque d'être un petit peu dans
l'ombre ces joueurs là et ça peut ça
peut jouer sur la suite de sa carrière
donc pour moi je pense qu'il est il est
temps je dirais même j'ai même qu'il
aurait vu y fait pour moi il fallait
qu'il parte là mais maintenant il sera
libre le renardeau lui a fait un pas
l'un vers pas parce que j'ai compris
mais là au moins il sera libre et je
pense que c'est le moment de partir
la gélule comme beaucoup la l'interview
dans l'équipe est en effet j'étais
bizarrement surpris par le fait qu'il ne
ferme pas la porte et de dire que quand
on lui a posé la question indirectement
de dire que voilà il verrait il verrait
en cours de saison ce qui ce qui ferait
je pense que les résultats du psg cette
année vont être prépondérant dans la
décision de m tapé pour pour la suite
il ya un élément qui s'est rajouté quand
même sur les deux derniers matchs de
l'équipe de france c'est qu'on veut
quand même pu voir une très belle
entente entre quillan mbacké et karim
benzema donc ça c'est vrai que ça peut
jouer dans la dans la balance mais là où
il ya quand même quelque chose qu'il ne
faut pas oublier tu le dis que en effet
il est aujourd'hui moins star un niveau
moins important qu'un quart mais qu'un
messi parce que je vais même pas parler
de données marque parce que pour moi je
pense que démarrer en dessous de quillan
et de ma paie aujourd'hui dans dans
l'esprit de la planète football mais
messi il est là pour deux ans il va par
signer à vitam aeternam au psg il est
sur la fin de sa carrière donc n va
payer 23 de mémoire 23 ans donc du coup
ça veut dire que en effet mba pays s'il
reste au psg sera la star du psg dans
très peu de temps donc il a une année
entre guillemets une année de réflexion
qui va lui laisser qui va lui laisser le
temps de voir un petit peu ce qui peut
se passer et prendre des infos sur les
futurs recrutements de 2 du real de
madrid qui financièrement mais quand
même et quand même très loin d'être dans
la position de du psg donc pour moi je
pense que kylie ann dunham ap et justes
dans une réflexion de savoir ce qu'il va
faire faire prochainement et je suis
même pas sûr qu'on ait qu'on aura les
la décision finale au mois de janvier
après le mercato hivernal je pense
vraiment que ce sera quelque chose ce
sera le gros dossier de l'été prochain
dans le dans le mercato et il n'y aura
pas de décision de prise avant pour pour
toutes ces raisons à là pour toutes ces
raisons les gorilles en moi je suis pas
d'accord moi je les ai compris
différemment l'interview mais je pense
qu'effectivement cette interio fallait
aussi lire entre les lignes il prépare
sa il prépare sa communication mba pays
l'a dit moi dès le début j'ai été clair
avec le paris saint germain en juillet
j'ai affirmé avant l'euro que je ne
voulais pas prolongé avec le paris saint
germain et dès mon retour de l'euro j'ai
dit que je voulais partir donc ça il le
dit dans l'interview de l'équipe donc à
mon sens mois plus tôt il prépare sa
communication il prépare les fans du psg
à son futur départ on sait que le real
madrid ça toujours été dans un coin de
sa tête très petit il était fan de
cristiano ronaldo et les fans de ce club
il veut s'imposer il veut se donner ce
nouveau challenge dans le club a du real
madrid dans cette casablanca donc moi on
avis prépare sa communication à l'idée
de dire là regardez moi j'ai tout fait
je voulais partir et générer de l'argent
pour mon club pour qu'il y ait un
transfert et qu'on paye mon transfert
vers le real madrid le psg n'a pas voulu
maintenant c'est plus dense et plus donc
voilà dans on va dire dans mes mains
cette histoire et je parle librement au
real madrid j'ai l'impression mais qui
prépare son départ et qui prépare aussi
les supporters du psg en disant moi j'ai
tout tenté du côté du paris saint
germain donc pour vous c'est acté il va
partir pour moi ces actes et on en saura
plus je pense d'ici le mercato hivernal
parce qu'un joueur qui va être libre et
dès l'été a le droit de négocier son
contrat et on peut d'ores et déjà avoir
une annonce dès le mois de janvier
florentino perez a déjà dit qu'ils
voulaient le signer dès 1er janvier pour
préparer une équipe autour de lui alors
signé en tant que telle non mais oui il
peut négocier un accord il peut
effectivement assez d'accord j'ai
demandé pour l'été pour nike et qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous - là où je
suis un peu mitigé c'est m à pékin elle
est venue à paris je pense que l'idée
c'est de marquer l'esprit de gagner la
ligue des champions avec son club de
coeur paris saint germain lui qui est
parisien est vraiment de rentrer dans
l'histoire du football parce qu'il faut
cela rappelle que marseille c'est le
seul club français qui a gagné la ligue
des champions yamba
oui
et et un bape est pour lui gagner avec
paris je pense que ç'a beaucoup plus
d'ampleur que d'aller au real de madrid
si vos real de madrid qui gagnent la
ligue des champions ça serait quelque
chose du déjà vu et c'est vrai que l
éthique des champions je crois
exactement avec l'association avec
neymar qui est pas simple forcément
parce qu'on a pu le voir à travers les
matches qu'on démarre et les poils à hem
bape et les idées forcément meilleur que
lui et là bas cette année il ya messi
qui arrivait donc je pense c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il est un peu mitigé en train
de réfléchir pour voir est ce que
vraiment c'est le bon moment pour lui de
partir ou peut-être de rester comme il a
dit tout à l'heure yann messi va être là
pendant deux ans après partira et que
lui reprendra l'équipe mais dans tous
les cas je pense qu'il va en tout cas
moi je pense de lui va rester peut-être
qu'il va finir l'année pour essayer de
gagner la ligue des champions avec paris
et puis après derrière partir pourquoi
parce que mba paix sur sa marge de
progression c'est mieux pour lui qu'il
l'est dans un autre championnat moi je
pense il veut devenir un meilleur joueur
et gagner le ballon d'or un jour plus
tard dans sa carrière je pensais c'est
important pour lui qui puisse porter et
l'étranger aussi peut-être l'appelle
aussi j'ai dû varier le ballon le ballon
d'or il se décidera avec les racheter
l'équipe de france pour pour elle
m'appelle je pense que les résultats en
club bouygues vont avoir une importance
mais il ya quand même des années ou
à partir du moment où tu es le meilleur
joueur d'une équipe si ton équipe gagne
en plus là
la coupe du fouet le championnat du
monde tu es logiquement enfin beaucoup
non
la pagani avec son nationale
sur le fait que pour progresser pour
franchir un cap dans sa carrière il doit
changer de club et j'ai envie de dire
quel meilleur moment que quand on arrive
à la fin de son contrat on peut partir
librement on sait que le psg après va
monnayer son départ très très cher on
descendra pas en dessous des 200 220
millions d'euros pour pour kilian mottet
et donc ça va être plus difficile pour
un club de venir le chercher je pense
que s'il doit partir c'est à cela pollue
prochaine intersaison où il sera libre
de tout contrat en fin de contrat en fin
de contrat avec le psg par contre
continuer à négocier un accord avec la
famille on parle d'un contrat de cinq
ans et un salaire net de 45 millions
d'euros ça peut le faire réfléchir à
votre avis les gens
là on sait que d'autres d'autres clubs
pour s'aligner ce genre de choses je
pense que j'espère pour lui que
sportivement il réagira et qui va pas
rester au psg
simplement pour pau pour les poulets
sont les héros je pense pas je pense
qu'il est assez équilibré encore là où
je rejoins pas trop où j'en sais quand
il dit mais s'il en a pour deux ans et
après un rappel sera la star du psg vous
pensez bien que messi qui va partir ils
vont me faire venir un autre du même
acabit ils vont pas rester sans
s'arrêter d'ici là des messier n'a pas
50 merci mais des grands joueurs il y en
a et b sg le problème l'avantagé ou le
problème pour les autres mais c'est que
ils ont là tyrolien qui est inépuisable
donc dès qu'il fait partie d'un certain
rock est de 2 très très bon joueur il
est proposé allait proposer des sommes
démesurées
à pour qu'un joueur puisse poser est la
preuve que p&g tient à qui elle bat p si
on se réfère une situation précédente
qui a connu le psg il y avait le cadre
et un radio qui avait refusé de
renouveler son contrat on parle pas du
même joueur est du même calibre de
joueurs il avait été mis de côté à
l'époque là pour le moment qu'ils aiment
mapeza semble traîner sa prolongation de
contrat n'est pas forcément mis de côté
ou penser qu'ils vont mettre qui allait
frapper je pense et ça prouve que le ps
a une autre vision sur qui elle
m'appelle vraiment on veut tout tenté
jusqu'au bout pour le retenir au moins
ne sommes pas c'est que aura bien sûr
c'est quand même et on va dire top top
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que les gars
sont très difficilement et aucun
précédent pg c'est le cas radios et les
télés relation avec leonardo pense est
qu'ils sont froides à son temps du mic
on l'a vu dans l'interview il lui en
veut un peu quand même une certaine
façon à qui allait ma peau est bien sûr
de toute façon ça à sa joie après il dit
pas tout dans son interview mais en tout
cas nous laisse présager des choses on
sent bien qu'il ya une tension autour de
tout ça
après wall s ils continuent à se parler
apparemment voilà tout va bien sauf
quand on parle du contraire exactement
si aucune pression en plus avec son
président depuis un moment dans
l'interview qui aime ma p 10 quand j'ai
vu devant ma télévision qui l'a dit
partira jamais libre je suis mais il va
se passer quoi à ce moment là c'est ce
qu'a dit qu'il ya la paix donc même
peut-être avec son président il ya
peut-être aussi un gel avec nasser el
khelaifi et l esthétique et statistiques
du bape et au psg on en parle 136 buts
en 181 matchs forcément c'est quasiment
impossible de le remplacer pour le psg
jean
sportivement ils vont aller jusqu'au
bout pour essayer de retenir oui
certains noirs une certaine renommée
après après ça va être ça fait son
chemin seul choix ce joueur personnel
est ce que lui il va privilégier sa
carrière sportive et je le pense je
pense que c'est un garçon assez
intelligent comme on l'a dit déjà auto
cette table qu'on l'a dit et grecs pour
moi sportivement s'il veut continuer à
progresser faut qu'il quitte le psg
parce qu'il va y va s'installer dans une
monotonie sportive qui ne va pas lui
servir donc pour moi c ur il est en lien
depuis 2015 mais la traite justement oui
il a quoi sert il met d'accord mais pour
moi il faut il faut qu'il parte il faut
qu'il passe qui régit réagira
sportivement et non pas financiers
remplaçant de la paix au psg vous
connaissez
il attendait j'ai pas son âge et la
saône en tête mais bon on sait qu'ils
jouaient dortmund alors
pour moi si mba peppard du pétition
alors de venir au psg aussi attention il
dit que le psg et jeudi le psg fera
mettra tout en oeuvre pour aller
chercher à langue voilà il tient peut
être battu peut-être un newcastle aussi
très riche qui va arriver aussi bientôt
sur le marché des transferts avec un
rachat par axa veut riche que les
propriétaires du psg voilà donc à
surveiller aussi sur ce point de vue là
mais nuke à newcastle web mais m et ce à
long terme et parlé c'était quand ginola
jouer là bas c'est ça
oui amap et peut-être lui être tentés de
rejoindre karim benzema son entente en
équipe de france sont bien fonctionné
donc pourquoi pas à les rejoindre car
benzema du coup les salariés kariwa
newcastle peut-être éventuellement il
est aussi sur la fin je veux dire il a
33 ans 63 ans il entre en 3e nul voila
donc oui je le rejoins trois aînés se
dire qu'on va pour deux années quoi
quand on sait que le psg a alors oui
assure simon casas neymar c'est qu'il
allait peut-être bientôt arrêter aussi
après la coupe du monde donc je vous
dirai enfin oui non mais qu'il arrête à
paco du monde il a dit qu'il arrêterait
sa carrière internationale mais c'est la
dernière coupe que je trouve ça très
sain alors il sera plus trop bon déjà ça
fait déjà trois quatre ans qu'il n'est
plus trop bon
je vous laisse juger en tout cas il n'y
a rien là pour fermer cette page un mot
rapide de la ligue des nations la france
a remporté la finale contre l'espagne le
dimanche 10 octobre face à l'espagne du
coup le score de buzançais le joueur du
paris saint-germain quillanais mbappé
qui a marqué le but de la victoire la
limite du hors jeu en plus des stars
parisiennes 4 évinois remporte la
compétition presnell qui permet formé au
psg tout comme moussa diaby aujourd'hui
en allemagne et mike maignan gardien du
milan ac il ya également matteo
guendouzi jours de l'olympique de
marseille originaire de poissy tout
simplement une belle victoire pour
l'équipe de france jean rapidement et
si si j'ai vu le match mais oui on va
dire une belle victoire c'est une finale
gagné une finale qu importe la manière
c'est la gagner qu'est ce qui est le
principe c'est le principal donc oui
c'est une c'est une belle victoire une
belle victoire après bon on peut
toujours remettre en question le but je
me suis fait expliquer parce que c'est
pas pareil que le ballon était touchée
volontairement il a bougé il a fait
action de jeu s'il n'avait pas bougé
effectivement il était hors-jeu sur les
images il est en jeu ses yeux même si
c'est gilbert montagné qui était à la
barre mais si on prend la règle
normalement on est hors jeu à partir du
moment du départ du ballon non mais
s'offrir bien je me sens que le bol au
jeu ses fans shirts et alors ces règles
y'a pas d'un ciel rainbow sommes
soulagés règles que tu aies joué j'ai
l'amour et qui côtoie je suis d'accord
doivent dire qu il ya tromperie à la
réponse j'ai à la questionne jeudi la
victoire et surtout à la casse a permis
à cinq de nos six vinoy de remporter un
trophée international voilà trophée en
verdon un trop fort mais je pense qu'on
peut aussi être content que j'ai le
niveau affiché on mettait en cause cette
libération qui pour le moment c'est vrai
à cette réputation d'être un trophée en
de chocolat trop fait un carton appelez
le comme vous voulez mais on peut être
content je trouve du plateau final c'est
pas parce qu'il y avait l'italie mais en
tout cas non mais oui c'est la meilleure
équipe européenne on a eu quatre très
bons matches même là le match pour la
troisième place c'est un certain très
bon match donc c'est aussi à mettre au
crédit de cette ligue des nations qui
peut être un bel avenir devant elle et
on s'aperçoit que mine de rien dans le
football on commence à apprécier ses
fans d'alfort je vais revenir sur la la
la la ligue des champions 2020 c'est
savais que
c'était fini justement par un final
eight et où on avait pris 1 il y avait
eu un engouement qui était vraiment très
sympa bien voir celle de ligue des
champions peu de petit temps de rêver
ressent déjà dit c'est pas tous les ans
qu'il faut le faire comme ça je pense
qu'il faut garder l'esprit de la ligue
des champions mais avec une alternative
une alternance quand ya pas de coupe
d'europe et quand ya pas deux coupe du
monde parce qu'il faut pas mettre la
coupe du monde tous les deux ans mais
justement peut-être de faire cette
alternance avec une ligue des champions
qui pourrait être en fine de l'aide ça
pourrait être vraiment très très sympa
très simple le joueur ils ont déjà
énormément de matches qu'ils jouent des
coudes pour le qatar ils vont être
disponibles pour les sélectionneurs une
semaine avant il faut arrêter quoi plus
rien c'était vraiment une connerie de
mai de la coupe
vous êtes ses traits limitant de publier
leurs intentions mike belle victoire
rapidement maintenant très belle
victoire surtout après l'euro a été de
l'équipe de france je pense qu'ils en
avaient besoin de retrouver la confiance
et puis on a bien vu que la map il avait
un esprit revanchard aussi d'essayer de
retrouver après le penalty qu'il a
ratées et je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est aussi important c'est
souvent en france on a des bonnes
équipes on a des bons joueurs et quand
ça va poindre on a tendance à les
critiquer rapidement ça fait partie du
sport de gagner et de perdre et je pense
que c'est important ils ont prouvé
ensemble qu'ils avaient envie de gagner
et puis ça va les mettre en route pour
la coupe du monde qui va arriver très
bientôt là je pense qu'ils envisagent un
match ils ont encore deux matches de
qualification pour la coupe du monde
vient d'ailleurs ce sont eux qui ils
sont et son esprit supérieur préserver
vous jouez vous mangez contre zoug et
ils sont là y voit là ils sont sur un
rail pour pour finir premier du groupe
et la valse et l'émergence d'un leader
technique devancé benzema on le savait
mais son retour fait beaucoup de bien à
l'équipe de france on va te tuer a parlé
football et non pas de griezmann jarrier
mais cette fois-ci de la coupe de france
on va jouer le quatrième tour au début
du mois d'octobre et calvin moi s'en
sont plutôt bien sortis sept clubs sur
d'où se sont qualifiés pour les 5e tour
on retiendra notamment la démonstration
de chatou 8 à 0 à 15,6 voisins autre
victoire à l'extérieur conflans sur le
terrain de pontault combault 4 à 0 pour
son entrée dans la compétition
versailles l'a emporté 3-0 face à
brétigny nationale 3 donc à une division
seulement dé versailles et qui sont en
nationale 2 la déception c'est bien
entendu le club de houille des faits
contre saint michel 91 un club largement
en dessous des hobbies loi sur le papier
et ce week-end à s'était aussi une
histoire de tirs au but cinq équipes
l'illinois sont arrivés au coude à coude
avec leurs adversaires au bout du temps
réglementaire et 3 longtemps porté je
pense à poissy contre gretz tournan
tracé au puc et chambourcy contre
villeneuve ablon chambourcy notre
nouveau petit poucet vinoy le club
évolue en d3 mais l'une des plus belles
performances de ce tour de coupe de
france et une défaite bréval longue qui
évolue en d5 de district s'est
finalement incliné face à vincennes qui
évolue cette division au dessus le score
2-0 les yvelinois en pris un but à la
fin de la première période et un autre à
la fin du match la question sur ce thème
peut-on déjà être satisfait le du
parcours de nos civils loi oui ou non
non pour vous il ya du jarrier oui pour
vous grégory oui pour vous aussi j'en ai
pour vous mike enfin petit duel entre
grégory et il ya du jarrier grégory
toujours un fervent défenseur du
football amateur je le disais leenaars
c'est l'une de mes envolée je veux un
petit poucet blinois très loin dans
cette coupe de france je vais pas me
prononcer sur des pronostics parce qu'on
sait que je suis mauvais en la matière 7
sur 12 bat c'est finalement plus de la
moitié sur ce quatrième tour qu'ils ont
c'est difficile c'est un tour on
commence à affronter des équipes qui
peuvent être en nationale 3 en régionale
une donc il ya déjà des gros écarts qui
peuvent se montrer il ya ces maillots
aussi ont revêtu les maillots de la
coupe de france à partir du 4e tour donc
y aussi un on va dire un palier
symbolique exactement moi je vais être
content sur le papier tous les favoris
voilà à quelques exceptions près sont
passés et cette surprise de bréval
longue on annonçait moi le premier une
grosse défaite de bréval l'on utilise il
a mis à lancer combien déjà moi j'avais
annoncé un 17-0 pardon au genre de vrais
mâles londres voilà je vais étaient
positionnés on va dire quand il y avait
cette vision divisions d'écart entre les
deux équipes visiblement notre reporter
sur place bixente a discuté un peu avec
avec les les dirigeants ils sont
renforcés dans l'intersaison il ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui ont joué
auparavant dans un niveau celui
professionnel qui ont rejoint cet été
qu'il ya qui ont rejoint cette équipe et
voilà le score 2 à 0 face à une équipe
qui était cette division au dessus avec
un 0 à la mi temps ils prennent ce
deuxième but en fin de match et en plus
de ça c'est lorsqu'il ya un joueur
expulsé côté bréval longue on peut être
que satisfait maintenant on va attendre
de voir les prochains tours et de voir
si effectivement on aura des duels de
ligue 1 parce que c'est ce qu'on attend
des yvelinois qui a affronté des à des
équipes de ligue 1 c'est ce qu'on attend
dans cette coupe de france mais au vu du
nombre 7 sur 12 le plus de la moitié
qualifiez moi je suis satisfait vous
n'êtes pas satisfait du coup
je suis pas satisfait déjà sorti voilà
j'espère juste que voilà on aura un ou
deux parce que là maintenant qu'on en a
7 au quatrième tour on en aura un ou
deux qui vont faire un long parcours et
qui vont pouvoir justement essayer
d'aller accrocher le rêve de toutes ces
équipes d'aller jouer une ligue 1 une
ligue 1 par la suite donc pour l'instant
on peut pas satisfaire parce que le
chemin est encore long
les matches des matches contre des
contrôles et contre les grosses équipes
de ligue 1 c'est à partir de janvier
donc il ya encore un peu de temps il ya
encore falloir va falloir encore aller
aller au charbon pendant pendant
quelques week-ends mais on peut se dire
que ben la route et plus est plus belle
que certaines années voilà un gros
parcours d'un club liévinois c'était un
manque nantes en 2016 c'était un 16e de
finale avec une défaite 1 0 en
prolongation en 2016 on a eu trop - les
visages vous n'avez rien reçu mais lens
était un idiot les policiers étaient en
vie que tous les docteurs france est
leader en 2018 il y avait eu 4 à 2 quant
au délit de ces drôles et eames et goren
sympa aussi et puis en plus voilà en
ligue 2 on peut aussi rencontrer des
très très belle équipe qui viennent de
descendre ou cookies qui ont fait aussi
les les baliseurs du football français
que le tarot ligue 2 en 2018 et qui
finalement se retrouvent dans les cinq
premiers de ligue 1 en ce moment
pourquoi tout peut aller vite mike congo
qu'est ce que vous en pensez moi je suis
comme greg je pense que c'est des bonnes
stats surtout au vu de
de ce qu'il a pu et vous allez leur 12,7
sur douce et je pense cécile bien après
yann il a dit c'est long la compétition
donc après je pense le rêve de ces
équipes là c'est d'essayer d'accrocher
je sais pas moi l'étude de ligue 1 ligue
2 convient non plus dire les autres donc
voilà c'est affaire à suivre comme on
dit est ce que c'est pas aussi propre à
chaque club cette coupe de france bréval
l'onion à n'a pas été aussi loin c'est
la première fois de l'histoire du club
qu'ils arrivent à ce stade de la
compétition parce que ça fait partie un
peu l'histoire de chaque club cette
coupe de france
je dirais que c'est la magie de la coupe
de france du football on en parle tous
les ans c'est c'est l'une des seules
compétitions vous avez une équipe qui
est quelques divisions en dessous peut
battre une qui est largement au dessus
voilà c'est la magie de la coupe de
france tous les uns et le peu de fameux
petit poucet espérant que ce soit un
club yvelinois cette année c'est tout en
fait oui du foot en général mais au
rythme des skate ou un mois tous les
possibles dans tous les autres sports
collectifs c'est impossible en football
non mais ça me semble impossible mais
qu'au football avec quatre chiens
divisions d'écart que qu'une équipe peut
gagner c'est pas possible mais
typiquement il ce format de compétition
ou pas tous les clubs amateurs de france
même ceux qui évoluent au plus bas
niveaux peuvent présenter une équipe
dans cette compétition forcément il ya
un côté rêve et quand les gros se
déplacent parce que en général c'est
comme ça que ça se passe un camp c'est
un gros qui est tiré il se déplace chez
le petit voilà il ya toujours le
paramètre à prendre en compte du public
peut-être le terrain qui va être papa
voilà mais c'est ça aussi c'est aussi ça
dans ce goût là coupe de france dans ce
ce rêve de la coupe de france est aussi
ça à prendre en compte et tout ça est
beau dans ce parcours alors au prochain
tour en tout cas ce dimanche 17 octobre
il y aura un conflent contre palaiseau
un trappe torcy poissy face à sainte
geneviève des bois un alléchant
chambourcy red star je pense que ça
retient votre attention grégory ça fait
ch a tout contre fonté sous-voie cachant
contre versailles et courbevoie face à
hardricourt voilà le red star et c'est
une belle équipe en plus ce duel entre
eux c'est quoi chambourcy étant des
trois ans et ça décroche en bourse y est
le régional et national qui a entraîné
par habib beye depuis quelques matchs
like et binoy qui vient du port marly
donc le retour aux sources pour habib
beye qui a également été dans le staff
aussi de poissy en football vous y serez
bon match peut-être pourquoi parce que
j'ai pas match mais pour ce week end mon
équipe s'est fait sortir de toutes les
compétitions possibles
on est plus grands championnats mais
grégory l'avait pronostiqué
ces pronostics être prise au contrôle
pas les haut conflent et c'est pas les
autres c'est dommage c'est dimanche et
ça c'est dimanche 17 octobre à 14h30
heure de match alors après plusieurs
sujets football au va maintenant parler
basket mike enfin et notre prodige
yvelinois victor webb anyama que vous
connaissez bien le joueur de 17 ans qui
a évolué au chesnay versailles est
aujourd'hui a considéré comme l'un des
plus forts potentiels du basket
international
déjà il mesure 2 mètres 19 et il n'a pas
encore terminé sa croissance qui fait
partie des équipes de jeunes de l'équipe
de france il a brillé cet été avec les
u19 lors des championnats du monde où il
a été en finale contre les états unis il
a été formé à nanterre où il a débuté
chez les professionnels et il a rejoint
l'asvel cet été sa progression devrait
forcément passer par la nba sera sauf
rebondissement à la draft 2023 il a déjà
annoncé et devrait être numéro un selon
les observateurs devant le fils de
lebron james la question sur ce thème
avec cet objectif de draft 2023 ce
statut ne sera-t-il pas trop dur à gérer
pour lui
oui ou non
oui pour vous jean mitigé pour greg oui
pour vous contredire dur à gérer pour
lui dur à gérer tout de tout
l'environnement n'a pas trop dur à gérer
on fait un petit duel entre jean et et
jan jambon
merci donc de trop dure pour vous moi je
dis non comment pour vous ce serait trop
dur à gérer ag ghaly trop dur je m'allie
produit en fait trop dure sur un drame
aux autres dur qu'il est jeune il est
jeune il est très jeune une fois qu'il
fasse très attention
parce que il va falloir surtout qu'ils
soient très très bien entouré
parce que vu
ses performances sportives il intéresse
beaucoup de monde et plus l'aura de
deux clubs intéressés plus y aura des
choix à faire et les choix s'il n'est
pas bien épaulé s'il n'est pas bien
dirigés
c'est ça peut être très compliqué plus
on a deux choix plus c'est compliqué
surtout quand on a 17 ans et connaît une
progression sportive comme la sienne ça
fait à peu près deux ans que je crois
qu'on le suit ici sur le plateau et
quand on voit là la progression en deux
ans de ce garçon je me dis que il doit
être et doit être certainement bien
encadrée parce que justement il prend il
prend les bonnes décisions et que ce
soit déjà dans les clubs en france il
prend les bonnes décisions mais ensuite
il faut qu'il soit vraiment encore plus
épauler et plus accompagnés parce que là
s'il passe à un billet là c'est plus
pareil voilà on touche au toucher le
graal le haut niveau et là il faut pas
se planter quoi parce qu'il aura pas il
aura pas de deux comme aux jeux
olympiques trois chaises sait s'il se
loupe là il peut se substituer la
carrière donc c'est pour ça que je dis
ça risque d'être dur pour lui
yann non justement en fait c'est ça
c'est qu'il est bien entouré tout
désaccord avec le jugement je dis non je
dis non à ce que ce que j'en dis c'est
que voilà on sait qu'il est bien entouré
les parents ont les la tête sur les
épaules il avait des propositions de
barcelone qu'ils ont été refusées pour
que justement il aya l'asvel qu'ils
soient encadrés par tony parker qui est
quand même notre premier
premier basketteur qui a quadrillé
cabrié autres outre attentifs saison nba
pour tout don qui connaît très très bien
le connais très bien là
bah oui au milieu donc il va pouvoir à
la pendant pendant deux ans le préparer
et puis on voit bien là sur les sur les
images quand on l'avait vu sur les
premières les premières fois on en a
parlé il était très très frêle très
longiligne et on voit qu'ils commencent
il a pris un peu de masse donc c'était
vraiment la première remarque que
j'avais eue là en voyant les images on
peut on peut se sentir rassurés là
dessus
et ce n'est pas fini peut-être attention
il va falloir c'est pour aller en nba il
va falloir qu'il va falloir qu'ils
bouffent de la droite il va falloir
manger du poulet
[Rires]
et donc du coup comme vous le dites
qu'il est numéro un sur la draft mairie
en fait six équipes de jeunes il a fait
le match contre les états unis je
comprends mieux pourquoi les états unis
l'ont déjà dans le collimateur après
avoir déjà maire il ya eu un reportage
sur espionne moteur qui par l'éditeur il
ya maintenant un an et demi deux donc
donc voilà c'est pour moi le chemin
n'est pas encore tout tracé disons qu'il
est dans la bonne direction un peu comme
deux clubs guînois il a il a pris les
bons les bons rails maintenant on n'a
pas trop dur à gérer pour vous mike est
ce que vous en pensez non mais qui
connaissait bien moi je pense pas du
tout pour la simple raison qu'en pour
plusieurs raisons la première déjà c'est
un garçon qui est bien encadré en
l'entendant sa manière de parler dans sa
pédagogie et et à travers les choix
qu'il a pu faire récemment ça c'est la
première des choses tony parker qui est
un pionner du basket français qui va
pouvoir l'encadré qui va lui apporter
toute son expertise et son expérience
par rapport à ce monde de haut niveau
on a pu aussi le voir à travers ces
dernières années c'est un gamin qui a
pris comme 20 kg ce qui est important
aujourd'hui de faire un peu près 98
kilos pour jouer à ce niveau là il
faudrait qu'il soit 115 110 kg donc il
est conscient de ça il ya quelque chose
qui est mis autour de lui il ya des
diététiciens il ya un entraîneur
personnel qui le coach qu'il entraîne et
en plus il a signé avec l'âge ans une
des meilleures agences en france qui est
comme sport l'agent sa bouna n'diaye
qu'à l'habitude d'avoir tous les joueurs
français qui sont à nba donc je pense
que ce gamin là il est bien encadré et
il le dit en plus il dit aujourd'hui je
suis pas prêt pour la nba moi j'ai envie
de faire les choses étape par étape donc
c'est qu'il est conscient du travail qui
reste à faire mais aujourd'hui la
l'asvel l'asvel qui joue l'euroligue qui
est une des plus grandes compétitions
après la nba dont qui sait très bien que
il a encore énormément de choses à faire
c'est pour ça qu'ils se projettent pour
2023 pas pour l'année cette année qui
vont parler de lui pour la draft 2022
s'il y avait un changement de règlement
au niveau des drafts de la draft est
exactement mais je pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui les prêts pour pour y
aller maintenant parce qu'il le dit bien
que yves appoint nba pour faire la
figuration alors qu'il est un joueur
dominant il vraiment de performer donc
l'expérience avec l'asvel de jouer les
jeep il dit et jouer l'euroligue je
pense que ça va être bénéfique pour lui
pour la suite de sa carrière donc non je
pense que tout va bien se passer pour ce
gamin à voir si si vraiment il se blesse
même au delà de ça il ira comme gay
parce qu'il fait demain 19 2 mai 36
d'envergure il a une polyvalence
incroyable il peut tirer il peut il peut
tirer de partout et dribble bien il voit
bien le jeu
au jour d'aujourd'hui sa seule
difficulté c'est qu'il n'est pas assez
costaud il n'avait pas joué dos au
panier donc voilà c'est un joueur
aujourd'hui qui à l'image de penser
pareil selon ouais bien sûr bien sûr ça
se travaille ça se travaille comme comme
toute chose de toi sans grégory est en
moi j'étais mitigé parce que je suis
d'accord avec ce que ce qu'on dit ce qui
a été dit sur ce plateau sur l'entourage
on sait qu'il est très bien entouré le
choix d'aller à l'asvel moi j'étais
plutôt mitigé parce que je trouvais qu
un inventaire il avait une belle
progression de venir tout de suite à
l'asvel je l'aurais peut-être vu
peut-être l'année juste c'est un petit
peu le club phare en france finalement
on m'a convaincu c'est vrai que la
présence de tony parker que les des
beaucoup dans la progression de sa
carrière maintenant moi le seul hic
c'est on va voir l'année là cette année
là à l'asvel avec déterminante parce que
clairement il monte une marche
supplémentaire dans le basket français
il va jouer dans un club qui normalement
est favori pour le titre ça va se battre
avec avec monaco qui aussi et bien en
lice pour l'euroligue qui sera un
sérieux prétendant pour l'euroligue donc
déjà ça va être une marche
supplémentaire pour produits moi
j'espère qu'il va savoir gérer la
pression il est très bien entouré mais
la pression ça va aussi ressortir sur
sur lui le jour de l'entrée de l'asvel
en euroligue l'équipe u consacré une
double page il ya des
observateurs américains régulièrement
dans les tribunes de l'asvel il va être
scrutée chacune de ses sorties va être
ai dit si elle va être analysée
premières sorties en euroligue il a joué
3 minutes il n'a pas je crois qu'il perd
deux ballons et il est contré à une
reprise tout de suite dans l'équipe on a
mis une petite ligne sur sur cette
mauvaise performance mais finalement
c'est tech 3 minutes j'espère qu'il va
savoir gérer cette pression c'est pour
ça que je suis mitigé très bien entouré
mais ce qui va être capable de hausser
de progresser et de gérer la pression
qui va être normal autour de lui ça je
ne sais pas c'est ce qui me fait douter
comme anthony parker peu le plaider
peut-être dans sa progression vous
pensez qu'il va le mettre un peu dans
une bulle ou m'expliquer un peu l'envers
du décor de la nba du sport du basket de
haut niveau non c'est déjà ça parce que
je pense que pour chaque athlète c'est
important le côté mental c'est ça qui
fait la différence des grands joueurs et
parker il a traversé ces périodes là
parce qu'à 17 ans par christian on
parlait déjà pour la nba même s'il
faisait pas de demain 19 mai donc c'est
à dire qu'il a déjà cette expérience là
il a ce vécu à travers les médias à
travers tout ce qui peut se passer dans
les coulisses donc il va pouvoir lui
apporter cette expérience va pouvoir
échanger avec lui au téléphone il va
pouvoir le calme et il va pouvoir
l'aider dans les décisions donc je pense
que c'est ça qui va être importé un bon
soir ouais je pense que c'est un bon
choix il n'y a pas mieux que tony parker
en france qu'on pourrait plus faire
c'est le numéro de téléphone de qui
l'adapei a quand même très bien gérée
cesser ses passagers a donc et qui a
vécu la même chose très jeune et qui
aujourd'hui doivent au plus haut niveau
qu'on le verra un jour au carrefour de
travecy varennes ne sait pas plus on
discute
oublions donc
c'est l'air de quelqu'un de très
intelligent très posé les dernières il
aida sur son calme face aux 20 caméras
autour de lui à chaque intervention mais
voilà la nasa n'a pas empêché de faire
cette saison vraiment révélation à
nanterre on le connaissait déjà la
saison dernière mais c'est vraiment la
saison de la révélation à dentaire il a
obtenu son bac à côté il a quand même
continué sa vie j'ai l'impression que
c'est quelqu'un de posé quelqu'un qui
sait ce à quoi il va être confronté dans
les prochaines années donc ça ça me
rassure c'est pour ça que je suis mitigé
mais je suis rassurée dans les propos
qui peut tenir dans les interviews on va
voir peut-être avec le 6 novembre à
venir à paris voir les matches j'aurai
des tickets je vous invite tous à
message envoyé
à les voir en tribunes parce que en plus
la jeep élite n'est même pas diffuser
cette année qu'on n'en revenais pas
beaucoup de chance de voir ici enfin
voila c'est surtout ça on va vous voir
rapidement peut-être les joueurs de nba
est un petit peu est ce que vous le
voyez mike jouer avec je sais pas lebron
james
ou autres franchement oui franchement
oui vous avez une équipe peut-être en
tête ou pas pour lui bon c'est pas un
peu loin mais personnellement non après
moi j'aime bien les lakers par rapport à
kobe bryant par rapport à l'histoire de
la franchise ben ouais je sais pas on
verra là où ils varient vatin de toute
façon aussi les surtout s'il est placé
premier de la draft et peut être
heureusement le oui je le disais un de
lebron james et un brownie james voyez
aussi une pépite aussi indue du basket
oui une pépite mais non ne fait pas tout
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
médiatisation autour de serre étant
donné que le père c'est un grand joueur
nba mais je pense pas qu'il est aussi
fort que ce qu'on en parle et le basket
c'est pas tout bill séparé le rugby
c'est quand même le sport ou les fils de
ont le droit à l'accès à la
un accès l'équipe de france là le rugby
c'est pas parce qu'elles
répondent
à cette attaque
minable
jouer avec tom brady ce serait bien
alors passez maintenant notre page
débats
on va maintenant passer à votre envol et
grégory la rubrique phare de cette
émission le moment fort de ceux ci ont
parlé sport de quoi allez vous nous
parlez de révélations qui ont eu l'effet
d'une bombe dans le sport français la
médaille d'or de tony yoka en 2016 à rio
se retrouvent entaché d'un scandale
d'une sombre affaire de corruption dans
le monde de la boxe amateur ces
révélations nous viennent de richard
mclaren le célèbre juriste canadien qui
l'on doit notamment ses investigations
sur le dopage russe le 30 septembre
dernier il dévoile un rapport
préliminaire de 152 pages commandée par
la nouvelle direction de l'association
internationale de boxe amateur laïb et à
elle les premières conclusions laissent
apparaître de sérieux soupçons de
manipulation des juges lors de certains
combats de rio-2016 sept à dix matches
seraient concernés et le parcours du
français sofiane oumiha médaillé
d'argent en poids légers aussi celui de
tony yoka qui a été titré en lourds sont
cités dans le rapport le chanteloup
verts auraient bénéficié d'un parcours
allégé dans le tournoi olympique pour
lui faciliter l'accession jusqu'à la
finale le tout via la manipulation d'un
autre combat celui entre le roumain
istor et le jordanien ia chaliche que
tony yoka a finalement battu ensuite en
quarts de finale est le rapport évoque
aussi rapidement la finale remportée par
le français contre l'anglais john joyce
par décision deux juges à un dans le
viseur de ces soupçons il ya aussi un
autre français c'est karim bouzidi avec
ce directeur exécutif de la nba qui se
serait arrogé les pleins pouvoirs dans
le processus de nomination pour les
postes clés est des jeux de rio karim
bouzidi avait été limogé trois jours
trois jours avant la fin de ces jo à rio
36 juges et arbitres avaient été
également par ailleurs écarté quelques
mois après l'échéance ce qui laisse
planer le doute richard mclaren précise
dans ses premières conclusions qu'il n'y
a pas de preuve pour le moment crede
concernant le parcours facilité de tony
hawk à mais des rapports finaux doivent
être publiés en novembre et en mars 2022
qui pourrait laisser apparaître de
nouveaux éléments est ce que le titre
olympique pourrait être retirée à tony
yoka si des faits de manipulation sont
avérés lors la question peut se poser je
vous laisserai répondre messieurs dans
un instant tony yoka n'a en tout cas pas
réagi pour le moment à ces révélations
son avocat arnaud péricard lui s'est
exprimé dans le journal l'équipe je vais
vous lire sa déclaration
c'est à cette fédération libérale se
réfère à la béa d'envisager des
sanctions sur ses juges si manquements
il ya eu elle les investigations ne
concerne pas les athlètes tony yoka
s'est entraîné très dur s'investit
beaucoup pour réaliser des objectifs
sportifs relever elle le préjudice est
double car les athlètes peuvent être
victimes de ce système mais en plus
s'ils sont médaillés il risque d'en
subir l'opprobre après pour moi et j'en
terminerai par là cette nouvelle affaire
ne fait aussi que confirmer un constat
la box n'a peut-être plus tout
simplement sa place aux jeux olympiques
de parts déjà ses nombreux scandales de
corruption ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
le comité international olympique a
essayé de faire quelques peu de ménage
dans ce monde de la boxe amateur laïb et
a été exclu du cio il ya deux ans et ce
n'est donc pas l'association
internationale de boxe amateur qui a
organisé le tournoi olympique de la
discipline à rio pourtant les polémiques
arbitrales sont toujours présentes à
rien qu'à tokyo ans l'été dernier maiva
hamadouche mourad alief également
sofiane oumiha on en a parlé un sur sur
ce plateau ont fait écho aussi à de
vieux souvenirs ya eu des erreurs
arbitrales qui ont fait écho à de vieux
souvenirs aussi douloureux je pense à
celui notamment et ses larmes d'alexis
vastine en 2008 à pékin peut-être que le
problème c'est tout simplement le mode
de fonctionnement de la boxe et ce rôle
déterminant des juges arbitres tout
repose finalement sur les humains sur
l'interprétation qui va forcément faire
des heureux mais aussi de l'autre côté
des malheureux quand dans d'autres
disciplines il n'y a vraiment pas de
doute quant au résultat final il faut
peut-être que les gigots compose dans
les prochaines années sans la boxe c'est
mon avis quel est votre avis alors il ya
deux questions dans cette envolée il y à
déjà tony hawk as qui doit perdre son
titre olympique selon vous il y au nom
des gens à voter
on va choisir
non pour nous vous êtes tous vous êtes
partagés janvier par m oui parce que
fait il doit perdre il doit perdre c'est
une question un petit peu ambigu il doit
perdre s'il est reconnu retirer son
avance il est reconnu effectivement
qu'il a fraudé qu'il a
ce dossier c'est que c'est pas les
sportifs qui sont inclus et ce sont des
arbitres après vous prouver la relation
entre les arbitres et les sportifs comme
si l'artiste outre-rhin les sportifs
d'être dans le sportif c'est à dire les
boxeurs l'effexor la l'occurrence le box
il faut prouver il faut prouver qu'ils
aient une relation entre tony yoka et
les arbitres je leur précise à ce jour
c'est ce qu'il a dit richard marque
l'arrêt n'y a pas de preuves tangibles
encore cédé sérieux soupçons qui pèsent
sur un parcours facilité tony yoka et
effectivement il faut voir s'il est une
relation entre des arbitres peut-être
courir à lomé et lieu qu'est ce qu'il
était et leur dire où est ce que là ce
sont les arbitres ils ont mis sur le
gril sont pas les sportifs là pour les
stores donc déjà déjà il faut faire le
la lumière sur cette affaire concernant
les arbitres et après prouver qu
effectivement il ya un rapport à une
relation avec le sportif et qui pour
avant de lever la médaille et j'ai envie
de dire pour une fois qu à ce niveau là
à la boxe aux jeux olympiques c'est les
français qui sont avantagés on va pas
cracher dessus justement le vit dans
l'équipe de france 1 puisque vous le
dites aux jo ces six médailles d'or neuf
d'argent et 10 de bronze depuis
1904 alors 1980 et dont la moitié ont
été
bonne moitié 2016 je précise gagnent
alors moi simplement enfin et ça fait
cinq ans quoi
mclaren là et il a quand même un truc à
travailler sur ce qui s'est passé si
j'avais un truc aussi là dessus je
n'oserais pas mais il n'a qu'à s'occuper
de ce qui s'est passé là au japon bossé
là dessus parce que du coup il va voir
plein de boulot avec toutes les
suspicions de la gouille qui qui peuvent
allaiter commandés dont il est aussi
voilà mai mais la voilà c'était à cinq
ans bon on a cette réflexion parce que
c'est au niveau du hacker qui était
médaille d'or si tony lucas avait eu la
médaille d'argent eh ben on appuie
dessus pour qu'il puisse aller récupérer
la médaille d'or donc donc voilà bien
sûr que le côté chauvin fait que non on
laisse l'américain john joyce
l'adversaire de tenir 40 nam veut la
médaille d'or mais bien sûr
intéressant si à noter c'est que joyce
depuis 2016 ce plein d'erreurs
arbitrales sur ce match qui a été décidé
par décision des juges et dans ce cas
dans ce cas aujourd'hui il y en a un qui
est 10e mondial look et 15e mondiale
allez hop on fait la révision fellahs
ont fait la revanche sur ont fait la
revanche sur un ring et puis et puis et
puis voilà mais chez les pros mais mais
c'est vrai que pour moi et je l'avais
déjà dit bien avant la box n'a plus lieu
d'être aux jeux olympiques elle ne
respecte pas l'esprit olympique se
maintient le cap deuxième question et
fait rentrer le terrain doit supprimer
la box dédiée aux
étudiants français parce qu'en plus on
d'année sportif on sait qu'ils sont
ultra méritants mais je suis désolé ils
font un sport qui n'a pas le schéma pour
être olympique on a fait rentrer un
sport le karaté qui nous a fait 5 jours
de super compétition au japon et qui
rentre juste pour une olympiade et qui
ressort alors que les coupes et les
matchs sont hyper fluide avec un regard
complètement
novice vous pouvez comprendre les
matches alors que c'est vrai que la boxe
quand vous n'êtes pas habitué eh ben
c'est difficile de voir s'ils courent
vraiment été portés ou pas eh ben la
boxe au revoir et puis on
mais on met à dos d'autres sports qui
qui vont eux justement mettre en lumière
des sportifs qui qui le mérite je dis
pas que les sportifs boxeurs ne le
mérite pas mais il faut qu'il faut
arrêter c'est pas possible et en plus
c'est vrai que je n'ai déjà dû aussi la
boxe il ya trop de faits déchets les
chez les pros on n'y comprend rien donc
mettez un gros coup de pied dans la
fourmilière et bah il serait ce que vous
êtes d'accord il faut supprimer ce sport
olympique depuis 1904 26 édition ogéo
est-ce qu'il faut supprimer ce sport des
jo honnêtement je ne sais pas s'il
faudrait supprimer mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que dans les sports individuels
on voit beaucoup plus ce genre de choses
là dans l'athlétisme on le voit dans le
dans ce qu'on appelle ça dans le
cyclisme on le voit aussi beaucoup moins
dans le sport co mais c'est des choses
qui arrivent très souvent dans le sport
de haut niveau c'est ça arrive très
souvent et là malheureusement v se sont
fait cramer mai mais en général c'est
des choses qui arrivent souvent même
dans le basket ça arrive
c'est ça reste qui trichent la wii
c'est connu ça même dans le match de
basket ça ça arrive des fois les
magouilles d un petit billet par ci par
là c'est des choses qui arrivent très
souvent juste que des fois on se fait
tomber de soupe c'est tout il essaie des
choses car il ya une double lecture
c'est effectivement la fédération de
boxe amateur a été secouée par de
nombreux scandales de corruption ces
dernières années là c'est le dernier qui
étant d'après ce qu'il faut noter c'est
que mclaren en général quand ils
enquêtent en général il ya de grosses
sanctions derrière le dopage russe on
sait que le comité olympique le russe
s'était lui est suspendu des jeux au
même si les athlètes finalement sous la
bannière du comité olympique on se bat
tous voilà tout ça mais
chez les russes à moi j'ai envie de
donner un exemple juste oui ça rien à
voir avec la boxe usain bolt je crois
c'est en 2012 il n'était pas du tout en
forme il avait fait une saison famille
nabeul et puis là les légers au bon le
mec il arrive il a fait un mois et demi
de préparation il a tout gagné enfin
physio les victoires mais moi je suis
sportif physiologiquement parlant un
mois et demi qu'on t'a pas fait une
saison complète elle arrive comme ça un
mois et demi tu te remets au niveau et
que tu gagnes quand tout le monde
mais c'est premièrement il ya le côté
aussi c'est finalement la décision d'un
homme par d'athlétisme l'athlétisme il
ya la photo finish il n'y a pas de doute
sur la victoire d'un athlète par rapport
à un autre là ça repose quand même sur
une décision humaine à chaque jour mais
finalement ici par exemple
usain bolt il a le droit de se faire
injecter des choses les desmans et ceci
c'est aussi pareil
je te rejoins et c'est vrai que le
cyclisme pour ça a quand même été
porteur puisque c'est quand même le seul
sport qui a tapé sur entre guillemets sa
légende lance amstrong qui a été qui a
été destitué de ses sept tours de france
c'est cette affaire de france mal et en
effet on arrive quand même à taper dans
le très haut mais comme la ligue le
dirgeant on le saura tu es sur
cette histoire de juge arbitre
finalement on va mettre le breakdance en
2024 géo finalement gens n'ont donc il y
aura tout ce qu'ils auraient droit il y
aura tout vu il y aura toujours une
interprétation ah oui la prophétie
artistique comme comment gymnastique
comme
déjà gymnastique auprès de la breakdance
non la souplesse mais c'est la boxe son
nom mais finalement on
tire un sport ça n'a pas de sens
voilà on peut pas voir comme disait
grégory il photo finish à la fin
finalement ça va être la même chose pour
le breakdance tout en en d'accord faut
le voir différemment c'est une
discipline peut-être qu'il sera éphémère
vraiment sur ces jo c'est que la france
est un pays berceau européen du break
dance moi je trouve que c'est bien aussi
qui est une discipline signature à
chaque
français et il n'y a pas de jeu dire
quand nexity
hrithik wade c'est facile de mesurer il
n'y a pas de décisions aléatoires et et
les français font partie des meilleures
nations et non ses moi que merci pour l
enfant dans ce débat-là sur le temps
vous connaissez beaucoup moi je connais
beaucoup la france fait partie des trois
meilleures nations au monde derrière le
avec le
fils du sud et amérique du sud comme
mais à l'accolade entre le roller de
vitesse hélas y avait déjà les
disciplines houde sur mer sera
spectaculaire et en effet je vous
encourage à aller faire des images où le
malheureux il ya quatre ans les
annélides à la question sur tony yoka ce
que ça peut le perturber ou pas toute
cette histoire à votre image
je ne sais pas comment il réfléchit
personnellement par rapport à ça après
je sais que quand un athlète de haut
niveau
en général si tu sais que tu avant nous
emmerder ou que tu avais pas niveau ou
cas tricher pour faire ça
son spectacle cessé dans la nuit six
millions est ce que nous ayons des
arbitres et du coup ça voudrait dire que
le doc de l'histoire
ce que dit arnaud péricard c'est
finalement il pourrait être une victime
collatérale à bien suivre l'arrêt
victimes mais je passe vaccin lui ça va
le perturber puisqu'ils n'ont pas c'est
pas lui qui était incriminée encore une
fois ce sont les arbitres d'eau que et
eau pour les sages de potentiels
électeurs ça va lui donner une rage pour
prouver que là il est dans le meilleur
dans le monde quoi excusez moi là vous
cherchez un
bon en tout cas c'est la fin de cette
émission on va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui on termine
par une citation de bernard tapie
l'homme aux mille vies qui a notamment
conduit l'om sur le toit de l'europe ja
goût pour la compétition il faut
toujours faire mieux et toujours plus
pour réussir je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]